في المقابل قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل ان اي وقف ليطاق النار سيعني حق
الاتحاد الروسي في البقاء في الاراضي
المحتله وهذا غير مقبول على الاطلاق واضاف
ان فكره قوات حفظ السلام الغربيه تبدو
فكره سخيفه حسب قوله وقال انا لاوكرانيا
للحق في نقل القوات والمعدات الى اراضيها
حسب ما تراه ضروريا
تضم الينا من مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي
ومن كييف مراسل جزيره حسان مسعود ونبدا
اولا مع موسكو ورانيا
هل هناك من ردود فعل في داخل روسيا على
المواقف المواقف الغربيه وكذلك مواقف
اوكرانيا بالدرجه الاولى
حول موضوع العقيده العسكريه في روسيا
بدايه جمال دعني اقول اني اتواجد حاليا في
مدينه دانياسك في منطقه دنباس هذا اولا
وثانيا اود الاشاره لان يعني كنا نتحدث عن
وسائل الاعلام وردود الصحفيين والساسه
يعني هناك يعني شبه اجماع على نقطه في
غايه الاهميه وان وهي انه انما تم ادراجه
والحديث عنه في العقيده الروسيه يعني هو
ليس جديدا فعليا جمال روسيا تحدثت عن كل
هذه البنود في وقت سابق على لسان مختلف
المسؤولين انطلاقا من الكرملين مرورا
بالخارجيه الروسيه وانتهاء بوزاره الدفاع
ولكن ما شاهدناه هذه المره هو ادراج
وتوثيق رسمي
ضمن العقيده السياسيه الروسيه لكل هذه
البنود التي تحدثت عنها كثيرا روسيا في
الاونه الاخيره ولكن هناك بالفعل نقطه
ثالثه الانتباه وهي يعني الطريق التي
عملت بها روسيا مع يعني وجهه نظرها ازاءه
تصرفات الولايات المتحده ضمن العقيده
السياسيه لروسيا لاول مره تتحدث روسيا
وتدرج ذلك في ضمن عقيدتها السياسيه
المحدثه على ان الولايات المتحده هي
المبادر
الرئيسي للخط المعادي لروسيا في العالم
فضلا عن ذلك وضعت روسيا من ضمن اهم
اولوياتها وهي انهاء ما تبقى من الهيمنه
الامريكيه وهيمنه الدول التي سمتها بغير
الصديقه في الشؤون الدوليه اما ما تبقى
وذلك فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه يعني بالتوجه نحو تعزيز العلاقات
مع الصين والهند خلق عالم او تشكيل وبناء
عالم اكثر امنا
واستقرارا ويعني بشروط متساويه لجميع
الدول هذا تحدثت عنه كثيرا في المرات
الماضيه اما فيما يتعلق به الشق
العسكري ان صح التعبير جمال هنا تم
التاكيد على نقطتين في غايه الاهميه وهي
انه في حال تعرضت روسيا لاي عدوان فانها
قد فانها فان هذه العقيده تسمح لها بالرد
ليس فقط في اطار يعني الرد المتناسق حسب
ما تم الاعلان عنه سابقا في العديد من
المناسبات ان روسيا ترد عاده على مختلف
الخطوات بطريقه متناسبه ولكن ايضا غير
متناسبه وايضا تتضمن هذه العقيده استخدام
القوات المسلحه الروسيه رسميا في حال
تعرضت لاي هجوم
حسام مسعود في كييف
هذا المرسوم الذي تم توقيعه حول العقيده
السياسيه الخارجيه ويحذر من مخاطر الصدام
مع دول النوويه
ولكن كيف كان رد فعل اوكرانيا على
نعم جمال لحتى هذه اللحظه لم تعلق الاداره
الاوكرانيه على اي من هذه المواقف الصادره
من روسيا اليوم سواء كانت
التصريحات الصادره عن الرئيس الروسي او
حتى عن وزير الخارجيه بخصوص مساله
السياسات الخارجيه والعقيده الخاصه بروسيا
ولكن كان هناك تعليق وحيد من
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
حول تصريحات الرئيس البيلاروسي الذي كان
قد اقترح ما يسميه
اتفاق او مقترح لاتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
في اوكرانيا وكان التعليق الوحيد الصادر
عن هذا المستشار هو ان اي نوع من انواع
وقف اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا ستعني ان
لروسيا الحق في البقاء في الاراضي
وفقه تعبيره وايضا اضاف الى
اوكرانيا الحق في نقل المعدات
والافراد كما تشاء ووفقه الضرورات التي
تراها مناسبه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا
كان ايضا من ابرز التعليقات التي جاءت من
قبل الجانب الاوكراني حول التصريحات
المختلفه اليوم اضاف كذلك عن الحديث عن
قوات حفظ السلام والتي جاءت ايضا على لسان
نائب رئيس المجلس الامن القومي في روسيا
عن قوات حفظ السلام في اوكرانيا وقال ان
الحديث عن هذه الفكره يبدو سخيفا ما يعني
ان اوكرانيا لا توافق ايضا على هذه الفكره
وهي فكره نشر قوات لحفظ السلام عند
المناطق الحدوديه او المناطق الخطوط
الاماميه عند الجبهات في اوكرانيا هذا
فيما يتعلق
بالتصريحات وردود الافعال من الجانب
الاوكراني لكن اليوم اوكرانيا كانت ايضا
تشهد نشاطا سياسيا هنا في العاصمه كييف
بزياره عدد من قاده الدول الاوروبيه شكرا
لك حسن سعود مراسل الجزيره متحدثه شكرا
كذلك لرانيا الدريدي مراسله الجزيره كانت
معنا من